[Music]
the vegan diet has been gaining
popularity in recent years and today i
want to share with you my experience
with veganism and share why i'm no
longer vegan i'm first going to begin by
talking about why i became vegan in the
first place and then i'll share with you
my three main reasons for why i'm no
longer vegan the first two are really
just main food categories that i had
issues with when it came to veganism and
then my third reason is really where i
talk about the health issues that i
faced and what i decided to do about it
also please note that the information is
time stamped below so you can skip to
your heart's content and if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up to
help support my channel and if not by
all means thumbs it down but please give
me some feedback in the comments so that
i know what to work on and i have to
include this disclaimer i am not a
doctor i'm not trying to tell you what
to do as far as your diet i'm really
only sharing my experience in the hopes
that it's helpful for you and
encouraging for you so please consult
with your doctor before you make any
changes to your diet i started a vegan
diet about five to six years ago after
binge watching the documentaries food
inc forks over knives and what the hell
after watching these documentaries my
eyes were open to the tremendous changes
in the food industry throughout the last
few decades our food is not what it used
to be with added hormones and chemicals
and gmos and most of the foods now on
the market after watching these
documentaries i never could see a piece
of bacon the same in a grocery store i
couldn't i found myself standing in the
deli section and remembering that farmer
talking about his struggle or the impact
of those big processing plans on the
environment the abuse that the workers
face
it suddenly felt personal it felt like
not only was it impacting my health but
it was impacting the life of my
community
so after watching these films it was
like this fire was lit inside of me and
i was wanting everybody to watch them
and i was out buying these cds and
copies so that i could send them to my
friends and family and i tossed all the
junk food all the meats and the dairy
and i started with a blank slate
or a blank pantry and let me just tell
you that as a mexican when you tell
people that you're not gonna eat
carnitas or carne asada people look at
you like
but that wasn't really a problem for me
i sincerely believe that the reason that
people judged me was because they didn't
know the impact that their eating
choices were having on their health and
the environment my first issue with
veganism began with these little cows
eggs
you see my husband and i both grew up on
farms so when i told him that i wanted
to have chickens he was all for it
actually the conversation kind of went
more like this if you want to marry me
we're going to have chickens in the yard
in all of the research that i found
about eggs i mainly found information
about their high cholesterol content or
the types of feed that the chickens are
given but i figured if the high content
of cholesterol is really in the egg yolk
and our chickens are running around
eating grass and bugs
then why not just eat egg whites
i never really liked egg yolks anyway so
it made sense to me to reduce the
quantity of egg yolks but i didn't
really find any data to support
eliminating eggs from our diet
altogether because i have these fat
fluffy things giving me free eggs every
day and i'm gonna let their kind gifts
go to waste
i think not
the next reason for why i'm not vegan is
this delicious delicacy
some vegans omit honey from their diet
to avoid or minimize all forms of animal
exploitation
and i have a big problem with this and
let me tell you why you hear a lot of
talk about saving the polar bears or
saving the animals from near extinction
but at least for me i had never heard
that honeybees are in danger with an
ever-increasing use of pesticides the
bee population is decreasing at a rapid
rate and this should scare us this
should definitely be something that
we're talking about and sharing but
there's definitely a lack of awareness
on this issue if we think back to our
school days you may remember that bees
are an important part of the pollination
process which helps our gardens to
flourish so for this reason i'm very
adamant about not only avoiding the use
of pesticides in our garden but also
supporting our local bee farmers with
big corporations making processed honey
much cheaper than the bee farmers can
sell for a lot of bee farmers have gone
out of business and this to me is a huge
loss not only for the bee farmers but
for our communities because not only are
we killing our bees with pesticides but
we're also choosing to support the
companies that make the cheap process
deluded jug over supporting the farmers
that are actually helping to increase
the bee population and better our
environment so this to me is like a
double whammy
i look at it this way the cheap brands
may be better for my wallet but i choose
the more expensive price tag as my way
of supporting local bee farmers so that
they can continue helping the
environment and increasing the bee
population because i for sure don't see
myself ever being a bee farmer
also as a fun side note honey never
expires so you can stockpile it for that
zombie apocalypse
and my third and most important reason
for why i'm not vegan is it is not a
diet that is healthy for everyone
those of you who have seen my previous
videos may be aware that i had recently
given birth and i touched on the fact
that i had some health issues during the
pregnancy
i had some symptoms that were just off i
had anxiety for no reason at all with
heart palpitations and this feeling like
a bear was chasing me like i had to
catch my breath for no reason at all
like even just lying in bed doing
nothing super dry skin joint pain other
symptoms let me not bore you with the
list
but it just felt like it wasn't just
pregnancy i had been pregnant before so
i knew that some of these things were
normal like fatigue but something in my
gut just said there's something else
after seeing several doctors and having
several blood tests i was finally
diagnosed with hashimoto's thyroiditis
and i was found to be hyperthyroid
during my pregnancy especially i had to
be checked very frequently because
pregnant women with this condition are
much more likely to have a miscarriage
and babies born to mothers with this
condition
are also more likely to have birth
defects
so this kept me at doctor's offices a
lot during pregnancy and postpartum so
after i learned that i had this i tried
to learn everything that i could about
it what causes it what makes it worse
what makes it better is there a cure i
had hundreds of questions i still have
questions
in my research on hashimoto's i stumbled
upon dr weston's youtube channel where
he talks about the link between
hashimoto's and diet
and i couldn't help but ask myself
but how i eat a plant-based diet i eat
veggies every day i rarely eat fried
foods i don't drink sodas and for the
most part if i want a pastry i make
myself with replacements for oil and
flour like my delicious pumpkin brownies
you see i genuinely believed that a
vegan plant-based diet could cure almost
everything and so i was shocked to find
out that i was hyperthyroid and not only
that but my rheumatologist also found
out that i was low in vitamin b12 and
vitamin d
and my diagnosis changed my perspective
of food even further
because before i had a very black and
white way of seeing food foods were
either in one of two categories good or
bad
tomatoes good
cake bad
but the more i researched the
hashimoto's diet the more confused i got
some of the dietary restrictions that
are recommended didn't really surprise
me like caffeine wheat gluten sugars
artificial sweeteners but you see
apparently some of the things that we
consider as good and healthy for most
people
are actually harmful for people with
this condition this includes things like
nightshades like tomatoes and tomatillos
eggplants potatoes peppers rice and corn
even peanut butter and some nuts can
also be inflammatory
this all baffled me because these were
all foods that i consider to be good
they can't cause my body harm they're
vegan
but then it got even stickier because
i'm trying to make a list of what i can
eat and what i can't
and then i'm finding conflicting
information certain sources would say
that these things are good and okay and
certain sources would say that these
things are not things like soy eggs
mushrooms and oatmeal so i found myself
very confused and thinking
what am i supposed to eat
celery sticks in water
my reaction quickly changed from that of
empowerment to overwhelm and anxiety
because the list of foods to avoid is
quite extensive and for someone who's
already on somewhat of a restricted diet
to all of a sudden learn all sorts of
new restrictions to take this was very
disappointing and honestly it led me to
unhealthy thoughts for a few weeks all i
could think about all day long was food
i would wake up and think what can i eat
or the day would go by and i would think
what can i cook that i can eat but my
own family can also enjoy or my husband
and i would go out to eat and i would
feel guilty for having had a sandwich
because i know i shouldn't have bread
where my family would make comments such
as aren't you not supposed to eat that
it got to a point where i would
literally wake up every night or every
morning with dreams about food and my
nightmares or that i was eating a slice
of chocolate cake
because i love me some chocolate cake
you guys
and i'm ashamed to admit that it felt
like i was going to spiral into anorexic
tendencies pretty quickly if i didn't
reset this behavior because it felt like
i had no control guilt was a constant
part of my day and i felt like i had to
hide food or eat it quickly before
someone noticed or made a comment and
food was all i could think about all day
long it became an obsession
and i began to feel like if what i'm
going to be eating or not eating is
going to be governed by others judged by
others or i'm going to be feeling guilty
for it then i just won't eat simple
problem solved but would that really
solve my problems will that really
restore my health would that really
truly bring me peace and happiness the
answer was of course no to all of these
so besides prayer i did what i usually
do when i'm not sure why i'm having
negative thoughts or what to do about
them i journaled
i poured it all out and i sifted through
the mess to try to figure out how i
could restore balance and for me the
conclusion was this i'm trying my best
to eat the diet that is best for me but
i'm finding conflicting information and
it feels like i'm stuck in a game of
ping pong and i'm the ball and i don't
want to live with constant feelings of
shame and guilt because of what i am or
am not eating i genuinely want to
nurture my body and live a healthy and
fulfilling life while also reducing my
carbon footprint but the very thing that
was supposed to help me and nurture me
food had become my obsession so i
decided i was done i don't want any part
of that i don't want to have to hide if
i eat something that i know i shouldn't
have or if i do eat it i don't want to
feel shame for what i did i want to
actually enjoy it and make it worth it i
think the biggest realization for me has
been this i have to have balance i do
still choose to have a mostly
anti-inflammatory diet i avoid dairy and
most meats but i don't beat myself up if
i want a slice of chocolate cake for my
birthday and if you were to invite me to
your cookout and all you had was
barbecue sandwiches even though i really
don't like barbecue i would still eat it
out of respect for you and gratitude for
your kindness at the end of the day i
still believe that a healthy diet is
crucial for good health but i no longer
believe that there's one diet that is
perfect for everyone our daughter has
also had her own health journey as she's
in the long process of being evaluated
for autism and the more i research about
that the more i learn that she has her
own sensitivities and her own
recommendations for things that she
should avoid that are specific to her
different than they are to me so there's
that part there's the aspect that not
one diet doesn't fit all but also i
believe that our thoughts are powerful
and the thoughts and feelings that i was
having towards food were typical of
individuals with eating disorders
and i haven't shared this with you guys
but i've actually been down that road
before i once dropped to 98 pounds at
five foot seven in a period of
depression after experiencing a loss and
i don't want that for myself i want to
be the best me that i can be and be
healthy enjoy life to the fullest and
give my best
so the diet that is best for me
is balance
i will continue to eat a plant-based
diet but if i have a slice of pizza at a
birthday party that's okay i'm okay with
that
my hope for you is that if you have
feelings of frustration shame guilt
obsession and respect to food that you
focus on doing the best that you can do
and don't beat yourself up if you make
one unhealthy choice
and always offer the diet that is
healthy and right for you just because a
diet works for somebody else doesn't
mean that it will work for you or be
healthy for you
if you've made it to the end my hope is
that you make the choice today to learn
about how your eating choices impact
your health but also the world as a
whole the documentaries that i mentioned
in the beginning have still been
life-changing for me
and some of them are
gut-wrenching and eye-opening i couldn't
help but just want to jump in the screen
and help those individuals but you know
what we can help it begins with us it
begins with you it begins with me so
let's make the choice today to better
our health but also the health of our
environment and let me know have you
ever tried a vegan diet what is your
current diet and what are your thoughts
i'd love to hear from you i thank you so
much for watching until next time bye
[Music]